each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
you
okay so we have a department that is
quite original because half of the
people have joint appointment and are
really in something else on computer
science I mean they mix computer science
and other stuff and I'm going to show
that we can organize a big mess with our
own data and actually we have we are
five people or five faculty members at
least working closely together in
bioengineering and we keep exchanging
data and trying to understand each other
and usage pretty complex so we try to be
organized with our data it's what I it's
one of our challenge and of course we
are open to suggestion so let me
describe what we are doing in terms of
application okay so i will introduce
basically what our biomedical project
and what is the goal and what is a
challenge and then Victoria Hill for who
is working in our department who will
explain some of the solution that we try
to deploy we don't want to reinvent the
wheel we want to solve a specific
application problem and I should say
that there are many collaborations with
the hospital so here we have three
people who are doing an image analysis
when we are the other UN iska kya wish
you a nice parodies and jobs or darkest
and I'm going to describe this project
and I should say that all this project
are closely connected to collaborators
in Mayo Clinic baylor md anderson and so
on so what we are doing typically is
non-invasive imaging for cardiovascular
disease for example you want to evaluate
the high abdominal fat volume or
abnormal heat heart function so what you
see on this movie here is the
reconstruction of the heart motion and
you can assess the efficiency of the
cardiac pump as well as the mass of
muscle you can also reconstruct the hot
and the vessels another example of
application is actually more invasive
imaging when you want to have an image
of the artery and you want to have the
localization of the vulnerable plaque
those who are responsible for cardiac
disease so this is a second type of
application and typically what we do why
it's not showing I don't understand okay
the movie is not showing I don't
understand okay sorry so it's on the
screen and not there what anyway I
should I tell you what it okay so
basically we have a 3d reconstruction of
the heart and all the vessels that are
lying on the hot so this is basically a
set of data that we produce for
cardiovascular disease and part of our
problem besides the fact that we
generate a lot of data we have a lot of
human subject we have to classify that
do special treatment and so on is the
fact that this project has to be a
cutter connected to some others so I
think we just no problem
so the second class of project actually
is a medical imaging but related to the
assessment of physiological activity so
those are probably the most cooler
application that i will show you and the
one we are not that are not so stand out
and they generate another type of data
usually when i work with the computer
it's always like that you know so so
basically here you have the 3d
reconstruction of the hot and the
vessels and we like to use that for of
course numerical simulation and get some
indicator of the quality of the vessels
to the doctor so the second type of
application is the work of you a nice
parodies and his team it's all based on
thermal imaging and nowadays you have
thermal image camera that are extremely
sensitive one percent of a degree you
produce 60 frames per second and what we
do with that it's a pretty cool
basically when you take a video of a
person that is sitting on a share
basically you can track that person and
focus on region of anti rest and one of
the cool things that we have to achieve
recently combining some physics apply
math and image analysis is that if we
focus on the carotid complex here we can
extract from a distance the heartbeat
pearls so we extract metabolic activity
totally wireless and this require a lot
of validation another cool thing that we
did with this system is a actually to
get from a distance in the breath right
so once again if you focus on the region
of interest here with the right tracker
by doing either signal analysis of
statistical analysis this is a noisy
signal that is produced by the system
you can actually get the pic that
is corresponding to the breast rate of
the person so it has a number of
application you can imagine in the
hospital for example you can work on
apni another application that you may
enjoy is when someone get very
frustrated with your software actually
the computer can find out about it by
doing the signal analysis because Bobby
or breast rate and how big purse is
quite affected so a third type of
application is in the group of
georgelakos this one is very much
oriented to clinical application so
diagnosis therapy and swinging
application ID epilepsy cancer on
schizophrenia there are some fundamental
research that are linked to human
learning languages and memory so here
what we are doing is that we can
identify brain activity with a new
generation of sensor and the application
are typically for surgical treatment of
epilepsy if you can localize in the
brain the source of the problem with
this type of sensor also if you can
localize the tumor with this technique
so it's the golden approach that
nowadays is using the hospital is that
they dig some hole in your card in order
to detect by electric now by electrodes
what is the problem eventually if they
open they apply matrix to your brain to
do the signal analysis of your brain
solve the inverse problem and localize
the source of course this is worse than
going to the dentist so what we are
trying to do is to do that with a
non-invasive method so this machine
actually can extract 256 signals and
based on that you can reconstruct the
source for example here are the source
of the language or whatever and there is
indeed in this activity a lot of
validation comparison with the hospitals
so you can imagine that we have to move
this data around
and unfortunately in this medical
business there is not so much standard
so part of our activity is to work on
the stand down and generate the metadata
so we can exchange our information
before we do anything with it so some
example of this technique as I said with
all kind of signal analysis and you can
visualize the activity of the brain so
what I've been trying to show here is
that if you just take the sample
application of brain tumor you can look
at the tumor from the point of view of
its morphology with MI it's a metabolic
activity with pet imaging or you can
look at the impact on the way the brain
works with emmy gee and EG this is
totally different type of data and they
have to be intact connected they have to
be stone you have many human subject
those are the application that we are
really working on and the thing is that
the you can also connect to that thermal
imaging of the face because we do living
experiment with human subject and one
thing that is not even on this
transparency is actually you can do
modeling of a tumor you have applied
math model for that so we need to
interconnect all this data this is our
main goal my part is more modeling and
scientific computing so I'm used to do
multiscale blood flow bio it transfer on
to modeling actually I work with these
all three grid guys so at some point
they wanted to change my name from gabi
to garba the keys that's the problem
with this kind of collaboration but you
have to use domain decomposition
multi-level method scalable parallel
grid because all these things are hpc
indeed and some example of this activity
for example they have shown the artery
that is lying on the hot this artery is
pulsating flow and it's moving around
and you don't want to spend your life
doing meshing so for example fast
prototyping of the NS navier stokes flow
can use penalty methods that's one of
the things that we are doing so
you need to have some capabilities I
cannot show that because I don't see
this when you need to have some
capability on frid structure interaction
or first the negative flow so another
example where we have to merge all kind
of data is a face recognition so you
want for example to identify a person
widest once again and say if these guys
in the database or not so you have to
combine texture shape and infrared and
some of the challenge of course in this
business is that you are different
facial expression facial earth you may
have twins illumination conditions are
different you may have different poses
accessories like glasses and so on the
air and so once again the nice thing is
that we have people who are doing a
image analysis with differential
deformable model so that's for example
that part you honestly capabilities that
is doing a detection of vasculature
using thermal imaging and you have to
merge and combine all these data once
again this is a lot of data so typically
in order to do this extraction of data
you have a 3d information with your face
reconstruction here you have 2d and
freret for the temperature map of the
skin and you have to go through all
these boxes in order to get a signature
of the face with actually going from
let's say 100 k numbers to a signature
that is compressed with 200 the bytes so
this works again it's generate a lot of
that on you have to combine them and you
need to have some a nice description of
that so the biomedical data of the
future are actually non-destructive
quantitative multi-dimensional and a
special resolve you have high
temperature high temporal resolution all
these data are very large hydrate and an
intensity we do need stricter standard
it's
hit there and they are multimodal so
what we have envisioned in this project
is to design new computation or tools
for that and we just got a large ma I
from NSF for this project and basically
we do have access to a number of
database in vios hospitals and we have
fast network to them so we can get for
example the data like ma I or PET
imaging that we don't have on site for a
given person and then we run in our
facility campaign of experiment so far
we do that for each group but we
envision that we are going to combine
all these sensors in one single room and
therefore the kind of architecture that
you need to have for solving this
problem is first to force on fast
machine that are going to do that are
going to process the data from the
sensors and dump that on a large beowulf
system that will be good for fast
parallel I oh and in the meantime and
you need a couple of let's say eight
ways of their own system like that in
order to do a real-time analysis and
check that your data are not garbage are
actually a valuable data and it's a
right to keep stirring them so we will
do campaign of experiment few weeks
drink the year and open a facility to
many centers and then a poster yo in you
do a science discovery and parallel
processing and data mining on all this
data you have stored here so this is a
facility that has to be designed for
this special purpose actually and also
you need to do a several type of
visualization like playing with
two-dimensional array of screens or
basically a large 3d video on plasma
screen those are different things in
terms of visualization the image
analysis the numerical simulation
the accusation of data of course it's
going to be it might be done in
different places as it was shown in the
previous talk so i think i'm going to
let victoria to explain now how we are
trying to deal with all this data and
organize them okay
Jim Gray made a great point at the
beginning we have a lot of haystacks and
usually maybe your application has one
haystack and you have the problem of
finding something or discovering
something on top of it in our case we
have these brilliant projects and labs
that actually they function by
themselves and independently and they
get grants and they produce great
results as we dr. garbey mentioned so
that our challenge is to deal with
several hey stats put them together and
with that information we can actually do
discovery these are medical projects so
we have issues to deal with the basic
issue is how to keep this information
private there's the privacy for so our
project once we combine these haystacks
is to keep that in private so once we
put it together as Jim mentioned we can
have scientists work against this data
to create new tools or discover also we
want the patients to be accessing their
information like I saw the doctor today
I'm going next week I don't want to know
more than the doctor does but also I
want to keep track of my medical record
and everything that happened to me so we
can provide maybe several levels of
access like full access when we store
this information maybe a different type
of access for the scientist to discover
and maybe a restricted access for the
patients so the amount of data we looked
at the EEG the brain imaging data for
one hour of recording we have 256
channels this is non-intrusive so the
brain signals are captured by channels
for two kilo hertz per second we can
generate in an hour of 15 gigabytes of
data same thing for the infrared so the
issue of having large amounts of data
it's an issue that we have to deal would
be
sighs the privacy I stepped in and I am
NOT a doctor even though the professors
in the computer science that are
involved in the various medical images
they are no doctors either they deal
with doctors so we have to acquire the
expertise in the domain and
understanding to the point where we can
create something that's useful what I
have here is our concept of how we can
integrate these haystacks into one
secure place and how to extract useful
information we call that metadata about
this multi modality data they come from
various sources from a hospital you get
a dicom image there's very large
gigabytes but that's something that's of
standard for the infrared group it's a
different type of data so the issue of
how to integrate all these databases or
forms of data into something that's
useful later on that's one of our
challenges what I presented here is a
web application so we want this to be
accessed over the web by clients by
doctors by anybody so what we envision
this is use microsoft we have built a
grid of computers that are not only used
for the we call this wing which stands
for windows grid is not only used by the
wing application but we have HPC
applications that use the hardware and
the software we are overwhelmed by the
amount of data and the type of data so
we want to use the largest Lego blocks
we can find out there so we relied on
Microsoft they provided us with hardware
in the technology we use the net we use
sequel server in their capability so we
are trying to do something quickly and
efficiently so this is the design that
we are using right now this is our
application and over the net the client
images either infrared each
data are securely so we have to encode
these files when we transfer them to one
of the servers in the grid and also
extracting the metadata out of these
files and story in a sequel server
database with this infrastructure so we
are using the Microsoft infrastructure
to build an infrastructure that the
medical applications can use so this is
sort of like if you like to look at it
like phase one of our project when we
try to archive all these sorts of
multimodality data again we want to
build this quickly I call this the wing
application so using the technologies
the net the asp.net a do the net we can
actually archive in store metadata for
the we want to have security and also we
have to allow access to the information
based on roles store this in the
database using a do net we can actually
extract and view the information we have
stored in the haystack and with this
infrastructure we can apply queries and
also do visual modeling so these are the
objectives that we have for this wing
this is the technology we used we do not
want to write everything from scratch we
don't even ask them to do that so we are
using what's available and so we built
the wing application as a web
application it has a portal where
everybody can interface with and we can
use the sequel server to store the
information the meta data about these
funds again we can store we can update
retrieve we can apply querying you can
apply functions that the sequel server
gives give us the data mine analysis
logging and tracking so again with
archiving the second phase 4
project is to create new tools also to
create new biomedical applications that
have access to all these different
haystacks so we create a super made of a
haystack but we have the information a
smart information store where this
discovery process can take place of
course we are using the Microsoft
practices and we are using the end peer
model this is the hardware we have I
mentioned we have a grid of computers
and so this is science can be carried
out by using the data stored anywhere on
the grid and the computing power of the
computers we have the e science one has
two terabytes of storage and we can use
that again each image can be up to
gigabytes so every day probably for a
medical imaging project you have
terabytes of data generated so using the
grid computers in there there are
storage capability we can store this
information we do not so the actual
images in the database we only serve a
pointer to that so this is the grid this
is the computer science and this is the
college of technology the grid also
extends with nodes all over the world so
it's not only limited to the University
of Houston as far as software we use I
mention p we use big Lego blocks so we
are using the visual studio.net and
actually we are using the 2005 and we
were successful with it in the sequel
server 2005 so right now the files are
stored on a science the big two terabyte
data storage server and the metadata is
stored on the same system and let me
show you this is the brain imaging
project we have like I mentioned we have
three others but this is just for an egg
ample so once they acquired the original
data they have a head cap and they have
channels so this ways are measured our
store in several files so if you think
of this is the data acquisition stage
they run some programs processing and
they come up with the channels where
noise is eliminated and after that they
are applying some algorithms to
determine this is a clinical case
receive the subject or the patient I had
schizophrenia or not now what you can
see here are all levels they have data
files they have generated our job when
we implement this is to actually store
these data files in a way that's
intelligent enough for them to be able
to retrieve and also to use later on so
what we have done as far as how to
implement only this application is we
have the client images that reside on
the climb machine this is our web
application and we allow these images
and again the type of metadata for each
type of file is going to be different so
coming up with a database schema for
each type of project is what's our
challenge we have to store the
information in a way that makes sense
for each project also later on that will
allow discovery also later on they will
allow all from the top all these
different type of haystacks to talk to
each other at this point for this brain
imaging project this is the server that
we use for the files and for the sequel
server so the client at this time the
phase one that archiving phase is going
to upload these files they will be
securely transferred to the file server
and also that metadata our challenge is
as computer scientists to guide
biomedical scientists in what kind of
information will be useful to them so we
have once we have we are implementing
archiving of the infrared of the
biomedical and brain images we have to
be able to query so we'll create tools
in addition so this is an infrastructure
that will create for all these medic
biomedical products projects with that
infrastructure we will be able to create
new tools to query they will be able to
access and visualize so the realm of
applications either biomedical or
computer science or whatever is going to
be open to new possibilities so this is
what we have implemented right now is
there archiving and again the challenge
as far as questions you might have
questions for us i know we have
questions for you so if you have
expertise in this area you know we like
to talk to you to see how you deal with
biomedical imaging would and maybe we
can now use you instead of but any other
this is what we are doing at University
of Houston it's very exciting the
biomedical projects you know open doors
for possibilities and we want to give
them the infrastructure using the
Microsoft technologies any any questions
any questions yes it is we have clients
and they get data like from hospitals
they bring them on CDs and right now
they're haystack is so it's they're
overwhelmed with the amount of data
especially when the useful information
about the data is in the header itself
they just deal with files that don't
mean much so by archiving the files and
extracting the metadata we actually give
them the tools to deal with their files
yes
no these are if they come from the
hospital like the mi data the header is
standards that I come standard the EEG
data it's a PDF standards so when
actually is recorded that proprietary
software creates the file that way so in
the infrared that's an in-house software
so they have their different header so
now they are not annotated but we can
allow you know that as part of multi
moral data you know to question
at this mm-hmm at this time they will be
independent when we say integrate that
means somebody an ADA can actually
understand and interpret all these types
of different data you have an answer one
one aspect is the fact that you have to
get access to this data and combine them
which is absolutely not obvious and the
second aspect is to add the right
application to fujian these data oh yes
yes that's the major answering a
question such as relate the facial
expression and the brain activity to
behavior and cognitive capability will
be answered only when you get access to
all these multi different haystacks
because the information for the face
expression comes from one data source
the information about brain activity
comes from a different one but that's an
application they will give you the
answer so I understand I'm not saying we
came up with a solution what I'm saying
it's very complicated and if we knew the
higher-level picture to suggest these
biomedical researchers store it this way
because later on you'll have a meta hay
stack but that is our challenge yes
yes when we transfer the files we can
compress them so will be stored in
compressed format our main phase one
part is to allow each biomedical project
to archive their data while extracting
meaningful information that they can use
I think right now they are overwhelmed
by the amount of files they have so
managing those files you know it's the
phase not one but yes compression is
because they are very large one is not
so much to whoever generate solution for
that we use all kind of tools all kind
of compression tools when we want to
communicate in me but I think our real
goal is to solve some specific
bioengineering problem and when we try
to solve this specific bioengineering
firm we try to combine all the skills
all the knowledge that we have in our
team and collaborators and actually it's
quite a lot but this is what is exciting
for the application but building the
right infrastructure will allow
answering many questions as such